I want to mention a narration this
evening. to share it with you all
regarding an incident that took place
between our prophet sallall.aii wasallam
and his third in command and his second
khalifa.
And
came to see the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam
and he had taken a nap or he was laying
on a mat a ham
and a lot of times
it's hard for us to envision the way
that the prophet sallallah.aii
sallallahu alaihi wasallam's narrations
work out in our mind if we don't have
proper context.
So what the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would most usually wear
his most usual clothing
in Medina in his home he would wear
an isar which is a loin cloth wrapped
around his waist and he would wear
another piece over his shoulders
very very similar or almost exactly
what it looks when we wear to go
for or this was the most common clothing
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and his companions wore
obviously especially during the summer
months. He had other clothing but rarely
did he wear what we call a thus that
looks this. This was very uncommon
in that time and in that region. And so
this is why we read narrations where the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam would be
narrated to have raised his hands in dua
so high that I could see the whiteness
of his
that I could see the whiteness of his
underarms. Well, how could you see the
whiteness of his underarms? because it
is wrapped over his arms this and
when he would raise his hands high a
person could see under. Also the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam when he would
sleep when he would lay down very often
he would lay down on something directly
onto his skin and it would leave an
imprint on his side wherever he was
laying on a mat.
And so for this reason the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam
said to the companions and alkari no man
is to pray without his shoulders
covered.
No man is to pray without his shoulders
covered. Why is that? because this is
how they wore this second piece of cloth
over their is.
And so one time he was sleeping and he
was laying on a mat and when he woke up
to greet Omar,
this mat had imprinted itself on his
side as it would.
And so Omar
started to become tearyeyed
and he was over overcome with emotion.
And the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
asked him what what ails you and he said
that which means oh messenger of Allah
the emperor of the Romans and the
Persians. They are upon what they are
upon of disbelief and in many cases
active fighting against the religion of
Allah and they sleep on beds of silk.
Yet you are the messenger of Allah and
this is your state of living.
Now
what we really want to focus on here is
the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam's response. This is a
reasonable
logical
thinking from Omar
that this is the messenger of Allah.
He's the best. He deserves the best.
These are enemies to Allah. They are
worse and they deserve worse.
However, this
is
not a clear understanding
of the comforts and discomforts of this
world.
This world's comforts have nothing to do
with a man's relationship with Allah or
status in the hereafter. Nothing.
Nothing.
A person being given of this world or
having nothing at all
reflects zero on his relationship with
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. It has no
bearing. It is not a gauge. It is not a
yard stick to look and see someone who's
going through difficulty and assume that
he or she is being punished or is
distant from Allah. And conversely see
someone who is given comforts and to
assume this is because they have done
something right that has pleased Allah.
This is completely wrong. The prophet
sallall.aii immediately
corrected this in.
And he said to him,
he asked him rhetorically,
"Has doubt seeped into your heart, oh
son of Alab?
Has doubt seeped into your heart?" What
does that mean? This statement here's a
few few words. What does it mean? Has
doubt seeped into your heart?
The essence of all disobedience
is found in giving precedence to the
dunya over the hereafter.
The essence of all disobedience
is found in fondness and love
of this dunya.
Young young men,
this is not a playground here.
The essence of all disobedience
is found in an individual giving
precedence to the dunya over the
hereafter.
The kufur, the disbeliever gives full
precedence or most mostly give
precedence to the to the dunya over the
hereafter.
The believer based on how much he has
gained with Allah in purifying his
heart. All of us have some of this in
us. All of us have some of us some of
this in us. And that is our mission.
That is our goal to purify our hearts as
much as possible and to purge
this love of the dunya over the
hereafter.
Love of the dunya has destroyed us and
it is found at the root of all evil that
we engage in or tolerate.
Love of the dunya is responsible for the
majority of broken homes. Love of the
dunya is responsible for the majority
of divorce.
Love of the dunya is responsible for 99%
of all of our afflictions, all of our
disease, all of our illness, all of our
poverty. It is all rooted back to what?
Loving the dunya over the hereafter. The
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
described
a time when the Muslims will become weak
and he mentioned that during this time
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will place in
the Muslims hearts a love of the dunya
and a hatred of death.
If a person really believes
really believes that this dunya is
temporary that it is fleeting that the
only thing of this dunya which matters
is what effect it has on the hereafter.
If a person truly believes this, the
more intense this belief,
the more you will see it in his or her
actions and behavior in the dunya. If a
person really believes
that this dunya is temporary,
how much will they fuss over their food?
If a person really believes that this
dunya is temporary,
how much will he or she fuss over every
little tiny word or inaction that comes
from their husband or wife? If a person
really believes that this dunya is
temporary and the only thing standing
between him and the hereafter and his
reward with Allah is death,
then
how will this affect our plans?
Think about it. How many of us have
woken up honestly saying to himself,
"Today might be the day. I want to make
sure I'm ready. If it's not, okay,
but it might be the day. So, let me try
to outdo myself from yesterday.
If we had this kind of belief, honestly,
surely, as sure as we are of our death,
that we will be resurrected in front of
Allah, that we will be rewarded for
every time we utter Allah's name.
Then how affected will our attitude be?
How different would our behavior be? How
different would our outlook be?
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam,
this is a very unique response. It's
very curious. He wishes better for the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam.
But if we are truly certain
that the more difficulty we have in this
life, the more of our sins are being
expedated, the more that awaits us in
the hereafter,
if you truly want the best for your
prophet, you would not desire beds of
silk for him in this dunya. Those are
things that belong in the hereafter.
It's a logical conclusion to see the
messenger of Allah and wish that you
could put him on top of your head and
walk around with him. However, what is
befitting of a messenger of Allah is not
beds of si of silk nor thrones of gold.
What is befitting of the messenger of
Allah and what awaits him
is exactly what we saw Allah give him in
this dy. And so for this reason, the
prophet sallallam
said to
he said, "Has doubt crept into your
heart?
Indeed, it is for them in the for us in
the hereafter."
And this is why we are commanded to
strictly
refrain as men specifically
from silk, from gold. And it is
absolutely prohibited for a believer to
drink or to eat from anything made of
gold or silver. And he said, "Sallam,
a person who drinks from a cup of gold
or silver is merely pouring fire into
his belly." Why is that? Why is that
such a harsh ruling for such a thing?
Because it is for them in the dunya and
for us in the hereafter. Sallallah.aii
wasallam our prophet tells us. And so in
closing, how did the companions see the
world? They saw it for what it was.
All of its promises are false. It
doesn't have a right to make the
promises that it makes. And it doesn't
fulfill the majority of its promises.
And even though as human beings we see
that and we see that 99.9%
of humanity has been promised and 99.9%
of humanity has been let down on those
promises by a shaitan by a dunya but we
love to be seducted we love seduction we
want to be seduced because we conflate
what we want things to be and what we
wish they were with what they are. What
is this place? It is perfect for what it
is and it is imperfect for anything else
that we try to make it. If this dunya
were our paradise, think about how lousy
of a paradise it would be.
How lousy is this paradise?
Nothing nothing satisfies.
And the more you do it, the less
satisfying it becomes. And in order to
enjoy anything, you have to thoroughly
be you have to thoroughly be deprived.
And the more deprived of something you
are, the more you finally get to enjoy
it. What kind of a paradise is that?
Think about it. I want to enjoy a glass
of water. I can only enjoy it if I first
suffer
from deprivation. I have to be thirsty.
And the more thirsty I am, the more that
glass of water tastes good. And the more
quenched my thirst, the less pleasureful
that glass of water is. Therefore, this
dunya,
it is a paradise based on deprivation.
contrary to the hereafter.
In the hereafter, there is shade, but
there's no heat.
There is water, but there is no thirst.
There's food, delicious food and fruit,
but there's no hunger. There's eternal
life, but there's no illness.
That was designed as a paradise. This
here would be an incredibly lousy
paradise.
Rather, what was it designed for? It was
designed to be a field that we
plant our sew the seeds of our hereafter
in and then we go home. That's what it's
for. And that's why we are so alien to
this planet.
We are incredibly We are the only
creature on this planet that it makes no
sense that we organically grew out of
this planet. How is that? We have just
enough in our bodies to make us able to
be nourished by this planet, but that's
it. Nothing more. We have no natural
defenses. We need clothing. We need
shelter. We're extremely frail.
However, we've been able to dominate the
planet unquestionably. Why? Because
we're not from here. We have an edge.
We originally came from the heavens. We
didn't come from here. This is not where
we're from.
And so if you look at this this dunya
for what it is, it's a waiting room.
It's a hotel room. That's all it is.
It's nothing else. It's a waiting room.
We're all sitting waiting for our turn
to be called in and then we get up and
we leave. Do you ever see someone
sitting in the waiting room building a
house?
You ever see someone sitting in the
waiting room saying, "You know what?
This waiting room would be perfect if it
had different color paint. I really
don't these drapes." Imagine
stopping off in a hotel for an evening,
getting to the room and say, ", this
carpet is atrocious." And you go to Home
Depot and you get carpet and you get
paint and you you spend the whole night
remodeling the hotel room to be just
perfect. And then just as you're
finished and you wiped the sweat from
your brow, you get the call from the
front desk that it's checkout time. It's
time to go. And so you fixed it up and
made it just perfect for someone else.
That is exactly what this is. We ask
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
that he subhanahu wa'ta'ala forgive us
our sins. that he subhanahu wa ta'ala
grant us the insight to see our reality
for what it truly is and to have the
courage and the discipline to fulfill
our purpose therein.
What does that mah?